yo how do you feel about like uh
the state of because when I first met
you it was probably 2017 or 18. it was a
long time ago yeah and um
I even think back then like
being a female rapper was like very
yeah I feel like it was it was an uphill
battle because you know we we always
hear people talk about like you know for
so long there was like just Nikki and
then everybody else and I feel like when
we first met like cardi was heating up
but this like movement of like the
biggest rappers in the world are pretty
much all female now and it's like it's
it's the most thriving landscape for
female rappers ever
um how do you feel like obviously being
a part of that growth and that movement
like are you noticing like things change
I'm noticing it yeah
because you know it's what it's four or
five years in it's crazy that you're
because I still look at you like a new
artist but you're kind of like you know
I still feel no that's why I said
earlier I feel like I got something to
prove yeah you're like knocking on you
know OG status low-key
stop it I'm saying like there's like a
bunch of new young artists who probably
look up to you now is that weird to like
have people looking up to you and you
kind of came up looking up to other
artists as well
um no because I feel like as an artist
with a big platform you have like a duty
to inspire yeah so like when these girls
like do come to me for advice and they
do like pay me respect I give it right
back to them yeah